we now turn our attention to another
important topic from my opening
monologue famed constitutional scholar
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
he's throwing cold water on Robert
Muller's Russia investigation saying the
president Trump is absolutely right
a special counsel never should have been
appointed in the first place now some of
the mainstream media they are now
sharpening their attacks against
professor Dershowitz even suggesting oh
he's preparing for a job on Trump's
legal team joining us now to respond as
the man himself author of the new book
the case against BDS why singling out
Israel for boycott is anti-semitic it's
anti peace I agree with the title of the
book and I agree with you on Israel and
and these people that support Farrakhan
god bless you for standing up to that
bigot and that racism that anti-semite
professor as I have my whole career
let's get into the attacks against you
and why you think this special council
never should have been appointed I agree
with you well many academics many judges
don't like the concept of a special
council we're the only democratic
country in the world that has that in
other countries ordinary Justice
Department prosecutorial officials
prosecute the Prime Minister of Israel
is being investigated by the Attorney
General of Israel by the ordinary police
I think they're criminalizing political
differences there but that's another
issue but we're the only country that
has special counsel and what's wrong
with the special counsel is it comes in
with targets painted on the back of
people and they have to come out with
crimes because if they don't they've
wasted the taxpayers money that's
different than ordinary prosecutors
that's why from day one the day Muller
was appointed I objected to the
appointment of special counsel I said
instead we should have a non partisan
investigating Commission looking into
the role of Russia
what did Russia try to do how can we
stop it in the future from trying to
influence our elections let's do it in a
non partisan way let's make sure we get
all the facts out because the American
public wants the truth they're sick and
tired of a Republican truth Democrat
truth we want the truth and we're not
getting it today from the hyper partisan
investigators I agree with you about the
criminalization of
little differences this this is now a
major problem in this country professor
is I will say this and you might
disagree with me but in the course of
all this we've learned some things that
should trouble everybody number nobody
seems to care that Hillary rigged a
primary as Donna Brazile said against
poor Bernie Sanders nobody cares but to
see that come--and struck and page in
McCabe and probably Loretta Lynch that
they literally put the fix-it you know
what 18 USC 793 is about you know you
can't miss handle or destroy classified
top-secret a special access program
information if I deleted 33,000
subpoenaed emails and then I asked it
wash my hard drive and then I busted up
my devices as great a lawyer as you are
I don't think you could get me off and
then the whole issue of lying to the
FISA judge in the FISA application and
not informing judges of what they knew
that who paid for that dossier that it
wasn't verified that it wasn't
corroborated professor well that's
something that a commission can look
into and if at the end the nonpartisan
Commission points to crimes or probable
cause for specific crimes then the
Justice Department can investigate it
you have career people in the Justice
Department
what is the Special Counsel he comes in
and he's targeting people and if he
doesn't find crimes he's going to be
regarded as a failure and people say
well we have an independent special
counsel but who was the independent
special counsel he comes in he brings
ordinary people in with Justice
Department experience most of them in
this case Democrats which created an
impression oh all of our she asked you
this yeah you know the Andrew Weissman's
background Andrew Wyeth had cases
against him yeah I got to tell you
professor when you look at the fact that
tens of thousands of Anderson accounting
employees lost their jobs that he got
overturned I know in the Supreme Court
that for Merrill executives go to jail
for a year and that was overturned by
the Fifth Circuit twice excoriated by
judges for hope withholding exculpatory
evidence Muller was was excoriated
himself for his conduct in the Whitey
Bulger case and also withholding a toke
taury evidence and by the way four
people went to jail for murder two of
them died in the jail they were all
found innocent and a hundred plus
million dollars awarded by a judge now I
understand why Muller and Weissman seem
to be best friends because with that
track record they shouldn't be
investigating anybody professor look I
years have argued against testa lying
I've argued that the Guardians need to
have guardians we have to hold
accountable every law enforcement person
in the country generally I've had the
Democrats and the Liberals on my side
often the Republicans and the
Conservatives who said no we trust law
enforcement now everything's shifted now
it's the Republicans and the
Conservatives who were saying those law
enforcement I understand but the top top
ranking peacock branches the Democrats
who are now saying oh my god don't you
dare challenge the Justice Department
I'm a civil libertarian a nonpartisan
civil libertarian today what I say may
benefit Trump yesterday it benefited the
Clintons the day before that it
benefited Bob Menendez I don't care
whether it helps a Democrat and the
Republican I only understand civil
liberties followed one day I'll bring
you back I do think the issue of what
they did was a FISA abuse is these are
crimes
I do believe what happened with the
email servers crimes and I do believe
they rigged an investigation and I think
the IG report will back me up on that
it's worth looking into and the IG
report should be made public agree or
toes via or to waive his right of
privacy and demand that the IG and the
Office of Professional Responsibility
report be made public all right
professor I see it thank you sorry
you're taking so much heat but I know
you can handle it